the word is exothermic exothermic is
actually a reaction or a process that
gives out a lot of thermal energy an
exothermic reaction or process is one
that gives out heat so if you mix the
chemicals very very slowly it all just
gets pleasantly warm if you mix them too
fast there's a big bang and there are
many many many examples where people
have mixed things too fast and either
had a small bang or blown up their whole
Factory so to illustrate that what I
thought is actually to do a reaction
that demonstrates a truly exothermic
process so rather than doing a reaction
that generates a lot of I don't know
color change sound in terms of an
explosion you know that there are other
videos that show that really well so
this exothermic process while it's not a
spectacular some hopefully you should
see the temperature increased
dramatically
the rate of reaction when you're doing
an exothermic reaction is very important
and what is really important is that if
you have a small flask like this one the
heat can get out quite easily because
they're just quite a lot of surface area
but then if you take something really
big much bigger the surface area is
proportionately smaller so the heat
can't get out so easily so when chemists
scale up make things on the larger scale
that's when things can go wrong
it's just like on a cold day if you're
thin you wrap up really warm to keep out
the cold but you're really fat friend is
running around in the t-shirt saying
it's too hot and sweating like a pig
because the fat friend's surface area is
much smaller compared to the volume than
yours is so what we have here is
something called calcium oxide you can
see it's in an interesting kind of
container not a glass container and it
says to open it carefully so if I
they're exothermic reactions are quite
safe just feel your body it's warm it's
warm because it's an exothermic reaction
the food that you are eating the oil
from your crisps is reacting with that
oxygen in the air and letting out heat
in a gentle way but if you set fire to
the oil in the kitchen you can burn the
house down because the reaction is going
to higher temperature and so much faster
so calcium oxide looks pretty much like
any other form of calcium salt
it's a white solid so what we'll do is
put some of it in here okay so we've got
about half a beakers worth of calcium
oxide there so approximately about a
hundred grams so the thermocouple at the
moment is at room temperature and so
ever in temperatures about fifteen and a
half degrees C and it's even though it's
inside the calcium oxide the temperature
is about the same as the fume cupboard
in the room so what we're going to do
now is add some distilled water to the
beaker and we'll see what happens to the
thermocouple
so immediately you see the increase in
temperature so it's gone from 15 shot
all the way up now to 45 it's still
going strong when the chemical reaction
occurs you have to start the reaction to
break bonds between atoms then they
react and they make new bonds and you
get some energy back if the energy you
get back is more than the energy you put
in it gets hotter so the reaction goes
faster it releases more energy and it
runs away it goes faster and faster and
faster but if on the other hand you are
breaking strong bonds and making weak
ones less energy comes out than you put
in and you have to keep on heating it or
the reaction just stops within seconds
it's gone from 15 1/2 degrees C to over
a hundred so with this become definitely
not going to touch it because it's going
to be really hot so the this reaction is
known as this the slaking of quicklime
so it's calcium oxide and water
producing calcium hydroxide